[SPEAKER_01]: Paul Rivero decides at 10pm at night he is going to venture into the great marketplace to find himself quality clay to create his homoculi.
[SPEAKER_00]: After two failed attempts.
[SPEAKER_01]: After two failed attempts of creating them with inferior clay given by the servants of Prince John, he dresses himself in a dark cloak.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you wear a mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're just going to go with your face?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to go with the face mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe I can... Oh, so you want to put on the thing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like one of the face masks and do up a costume?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, that takes too much time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's already 10 at night.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to go get the clay and go to bed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, but you do pull a fake skin over your head.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so as long as somebody's not looking at you directly...
[SPEAKER_01]: They'll think you're just a face, but if they look at you and take any kind of time to look at your features...
[SPEAKER_01]: They can see the cracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, they'll see the cracks and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: They'll think it's weird, but actually, they'll probably think it's less weird than your face.
[SPEAKER_01]: So... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the way it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: You throw on the cloak, put on your boots.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you taking your short sword and your dagger?
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anything else?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just my money.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your coin purse.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: How much coinage do you want to take with you?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm assuming it's then this barrel of money that I have.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, you probably have a hundred gold coins in your room.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, so I'll just take that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you take a hundred gold coins and put it on your pouch?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And again, you walk through the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are not many servants.
[SPEAKER_01]: The guards let you out of the doors of the palace, as they always do, and you walk out of the protection of the fortifications of the palace of Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Down the hill towards the Market District, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, what path to the Market District do you want to take?
[SPEAKER_01]: I just need to get there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, there are two ways you can go.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can go through the Harbor District, which is kind of the longer way around, which has more guards.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or you can go through the Foreign District,
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is very dangerous because it has the foreigners, isn't watched by guards and is shorter to get to the Grand Market.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can see where this is going.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is the time difference between these two?
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say 20 minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's like, what, 20 minutes for the quick wrap, 40 minutes for 45 minutes?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's about 10 minutes for the foreign district because you actually... To go to the harbor district, you have to go down the seawall all the way around to the harbor district and up to the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: In the foreign district, you just go down like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: The foreign district is right up against the Grand Market because the Grand Market is where all the foreigners go to trade and do their stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll go through the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you pass through the fortifications of the Royal Hill.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's where all the nobility in Monmurg lives.
[SPEAKER_01]: Through the Great Wall that protects it.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a short bit of fortification.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you go through that fortification, the guards on the wall, one of them calls down to you, who goes there?
[SPEAKER_01]: He knows you're walking from the Royal District though, so he's polite.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're walking the other way, he would not be.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd walk up to him and discreetly say, I'm Paul Rivera.
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks you up and down and says, Sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're out late tonight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have important matters to attend to right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Important matters, hey?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: This way?
[SPEAKER_01]: He points to the 4th District.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: Will you be passing this way again tonight?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, I will.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I don't, then I will be going through the Harvard District.
[SPEAKER_01]: Should I have a messenger sent to the Harbor District to say that you will come through?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll either be going back to the Harbor District or back this way, so yes, please.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sir, to be honest with you, I'm concerned.
[SPEAKER_01]: How will the guards know it is you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell them.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll get the word out tonight.
[SPEAKER_01]: You realize that this is actually a very special thing for him to open the gate for you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because...
[SPEAKER_01]: They never open the gate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well...
[SPEAKER_01]: As soon as the gate opens, off in the distance, like 80 feet away, you see a weird form run across from one alleyway to the next on this dark indie street.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm in too deep now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't puss out now.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, I go in.
[SPEAKER_00]: I go in.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so you walk in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and start walking down the streets.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna play the part, look cool, look dangerous.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, I've got a, well, I guess I can't do a don't F with me face, but... You walk with confidence, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Your hand on your short sword.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's just keep going.
[SPEAKER_01]: So anyway, you walk down the streets of the foreign district and the smells are...
[SPEAKER_00]: Burning tires.
[SPEAKER_01]: You wish it was burning tires.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only kind of thing that human filth can possibly be.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like...
[SPEAKER_01]: They range from pools of
[SPEAKER_01]: Fetid vegetable that smelled like a coconut took a shit in seaweed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is actually good to rotting fish and worse.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you walk down the street though, there are
[SPEAKER_01]: Places that are open, light streaming from them, people that you can hear partying, taverns, foreign voices.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you stick to the main street, you feel somewhat safer.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are patrols that come through, though not many.
[SPEAKER_01]: When the patrol comes through, it is mercenaries.
[SPEAKER_01]: Coming from the Harbor District that are well armed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve men with a place to go to do something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like capture somebody and beat them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now do you want to dally in this district and look at it or just go to the Grand Market?
[SPEAKER_01]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just passing through.
[SPEAKER_01]: No little perception check.
[SPEAKER_00]: No side conversations.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, hey, look at this rock I've got.
[SPEAKER_00]: None of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: As you walk, you get the feeling that there's somebody following you.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Out of the corner of your eye, as a group of guards pass, you turn, and someone darts into an alleyway.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was it for you, or was it the guards that it was avoiding?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sticking around to find out.
[SPEAKER_00]: You keep moving.
[SPEAKER_01]: Again, later on down the road, maybe another 100 feet, the corner of your eye catches a dark form moving into an alley behind you, trying to keep abreast, not abreast of you, but trying to keep close to you, maybe 60 feet behind.
[SPEAKER_00]: I keep going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me know if he gets closer.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't notice it anymore, and they reach the gates of the great market.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tents from all over the place are set up, however, less than you remember from last year.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say maybe a quarter of the tents are here that you remember from the last great trading cycle, which is strange at this point in the year when there are usually quite a few.
[SPEAKER_00]: Economy's not too good, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, I go in looking for some clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you walk around.
[SPEAKER_01]: The merchants are still trading, however, at this time of night.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are still deals to be had.
[SPEAKER_01]: You look for artisan supplies or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: You carouse.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a in check.
[SPEAKER_01]: See what you find.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the first hour.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna be 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: You find yourself attracted to a pottery display where large ceramic pots and cisterns are created.
[SPEAKER_01]: The merchant speaking in some strange accent, but in common.
[SPEAKER_01]: You think it's backloonish, but you're not sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: A ton from far west.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you sell clay?
[SPEAKER_01]: The man looks at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dark skin, strange, bristly red hair.
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks at you and goes, Clay!
[SPEAKER_01]: I have clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you wish?
[SPEAKER_01]: He reaches down into his thing and brings up a pot.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need some good, solid, valuable clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What kind of clay do you wish?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you wish artisan clay?
[SPEAKER_01]: And he points to this vase that was created, exquisite.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want something that is more durable?
[SPEAKER_01]: He slaps on another large pot.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, Oils, whale oils, can be kept here.
[SPEAKER_01]: They will not rot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sealed with wax.
[SPEAKER_01]: The oil will not rot.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do I think I need?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, what do you think you want your homunculae to be?
[SPEAKER_01]: Durable.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want it to be strong?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want it to be waterproof?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you want it to be smooth?
[SPEAKER_00]: Waterproof would probably be good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because that would suck if it just rained and dissolved.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would be lame.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, waterproof.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would be good.
[SPEAKER_01]: You wish it to hold water.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would say this.
[SPEAKER_01]: He pulls out this lump of clay and puts it down.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, the best bowls, the best containers are made from this.
[SPEAKER_01]: This pot, and he claps on the large thing, is made from this.
[SPEAKER_01]: That'd be funny if it just shattered.
[SPEAKER_01]: That'd be really funny.
[SPEAKER_01]: As it goes, oh yeah, I don't want that clay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, how much?
[SPEAKER_00]: For this much, Clay?
[SPEAKER_01]: A gold coin.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is from the far nation to the west.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Bakloonish Empire.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much is this?
[SPEAKER_00]: How much is this, Clay?
[SPEAKER_00]: One gold coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, how much is in weight?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I would say about ten pounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, for a gold coin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, give me like... Give me like two or three gold coins worth in case I mess up again.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have to... You would have heard it, Sen. You're interested in making art, I take it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, if you could say so.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he goes over and brings out more clay, puts it down, and goes, very well, thirty pounds for three gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, the clay...
[SPEAKER_00]: I want a bag for this or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you ask, do you say, give me a bag?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, do you guys have a bag for this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Of course!
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes, I'll throw that in for free.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he throws it down in front of you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I give him a gold coin, I put it away and... Three gold coins, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I give him another gold coin for the bag.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just being generous.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sir, you are very generous to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: No problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: You must be a great lord.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wealthy merchant then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would you have a good eye for clay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I take my clay and I get on my way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you don't want to see anything else?
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: What else do they have here in this version?
[SPEAKER_00]: I should take advantage of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you want to look for?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do they got?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do they got weapons?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, there are weapons.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are weapons around.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see mini weapon shops with strange swords, hammers, flails, lances from the East, the Great Kingdom, whips, harpoons.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do we got for daggers?
[SPEAKER_00]: If I go up to one of them and ask them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where's one of your best daggers?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to go to a weapon maker and ask for a dagger?
[SPEAKER_01]: So the man says, what kind of weapon would you like?
[SPEAKER_00]: Would you like something for cutting?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you wish to have a stiletto?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, a dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: A stiletto is a dagger he pulls out.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a stiletto, which he shows to be a long knife, probably about 12 inches in length, but very thin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, it's a stabbing dagger, used not necessarily for combat, but for backstabs.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes, how about this?
[SPEAKER_01]: He puts the tip down.
[SPEAKER_01]: The metal, Dulkheim steel, from the Crystal Mist Mountains, the dwarves made it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Forged by the assassins of Earty.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I think he's telling the truth?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I roll insight?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna say, like, this... 14.
[SPEAKER_00]: 14.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably not forged by its acids, but the quality of the metal is actually very good.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's an upgrade from mine?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's sharp, and the tip
[SPEAKER_01]: It looks like it could go through chain mail easily.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Without breaking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it come with a sheath?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did you ask him that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: A sheath will certainly serve her.
[SPEAKER_01]: He reaches back and says, here we are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Iron wood.
[SPEAKER_01]: Held together with the finest irons.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's actually kind of a nice piece.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, what's it look like?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the blade itself is that long, like I said, with the handle, but the handle is small.
[SPEAKER_01]: Only one hand, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And there's a cross guard that kind of tips out like that, and you realize that's to make sure that anybody's sword does not come down and cut off your finger or another blade, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could probably get the entire blade into somebody.
[SPEAKER_01]: The metal seems very hard, and the blade at the tip is very sharp, even though lower down on the blade it basically just turns into a round dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: So once you get the blade in, you can shove more in to the wound, but it's not bladed itself.
[SPEAKER_01]: So really, probably only that much of it would be something you'd want to stick in.
[SPEAKER_01]: But the good thing about that is this part of it is sturdy.
[SPEAKER_00]: It will not break.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the sheath itself is well-made and the wood seems to be pleasing to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And even though it's very simple, it doesn't have carvings or anything like that,
[SPEAKER_01]: It is made of very good material and the utility of it is attractive to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think what's most attractive to you, however, is the fact that both the sheath and the metal is dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: And only the sharp edge reflects light.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this could be used in the shadows.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I like this.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much?
[SPEAKER_01]: He kind of looks around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifty gold coins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thirty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do a charisma check.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six to four.
[SPEAKER_00]: You insult me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Forty-five.
[SPEAKER_01]: That is not an insult.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, watch.
[SPEAKER_01]: He takes the blade, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And he walks over to a suit of chain mail that is kind of, obviously it's like a suit that is used to show how good his weapons are.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he goes, watch this.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he shoves the dagger into it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can tell that the guy is actually an expert with a dagger and this easily goes through the chain and the leather underneath it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously this is for attacking armored people and you can see how it would cut through most of those things.
[SPEAKER_01]: He pulls a knife out and he says, try that with your blade.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you pull your broad dirk out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is a very sharp weapon.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually against unarmored opponents it can be both as a slashing weapon or a stabbing weapon.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's broader and it doesn't have that kind of tip.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't expect it to do much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you stab?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you take your weapon and stab it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your 20 so I die.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: A five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the blade, the tip of the blade is stopped by the chain.
[SPEAKER_01]: This would go into a normal suit of leather.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, a chainmail would stop it completely.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a good purpose for this, and he like puts the thing back in the sheath.
[SPEAKER_01]: 50 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: 46.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're a man that won't stop.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've already spent a fair amount of my gold.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it 46 that you have now?
[SPEAKER_00]: 46.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or are you just looking for dinner?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm four gold pieces off fifty.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you're really gonna fight me tooth and nail for those four gold pieces, then...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know what financial situation you're in, brother, but... Well, this year has been poor.
[SPEAKER_01]: The barricade has made things difficult.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm trying to make as much money as I possibly can here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought... Me too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the Kurtzman check again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me just clear all this stuff out of the way.
[SPEAKER_00]: He puts it down.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just need to get a scary, deadly mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I need.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will give it to you for 48.
[SPEAKER_01]: Done.
[SPEAKER_01]: He puts the deck again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Put down 48 gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you've spent 51 so far.
[SPEAKER_01]: 52.
[SPEAKER_01]: 52 so far.
[SPEAKER_01]: You give the guy a tip.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: For the bag.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes, here's to hoping that things improve for us merchants.
[SPEAKER_00]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_00]: This has been a bad year.
[SPEAKER_00]: It has.
[SPEAKER_00]: As I look around and see hardly any tents.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, I leave.
[SPEAKER_00]: What other stores we got?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, is there anything special?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this like a plus one weapon?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you touch it?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's very sharp.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I need to touch it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so this is a special weapon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is not a plus one dagger.
[SPEAKER_01]: What this is is a dagger that gets plus two on opponents, not in damage, but plus two to hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: On opponents that are wearing medium or heavy armor.
[SPEAKER_01]: If somebody is wearing just normal armor, like light armor or no armor, you don't get that bonus.
[SPEAKER_01]: But this is very useful against armored opponents.
[SPEAKER_00]: On medium or heavy armor?
[SPEAKER_01]: Medium or heavy armor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sweet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there anything else that catches my eye?
[SPEAKER_01]: As you walk through, is there anything else that you're interested in?
[SPEAKER_00]: Herbs?
[SPEAKER_00]: Opium?
[SPEAKER_00]: I learned my lesson.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure I've still got some work.
[SPEAKER_00]: What even happened with it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why... What happened?
[SPEAKER_01]: I took so much opium that I... What happened was this.
[SPEAKER_01]: The opium that your servants have given you...
[SPEAKER_01]: Normally you have opium sticks that you use to light yourself.
[SPEAKER_01]: But these were like black opium sticks.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the smoke was much thicker and much heavier.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but what did I do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I did something that...
[SPEAKER_01]: It brought memories to your head.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And it brought into your mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: When I was in that basement and I was like, dude, that opium is like... Yeah, I like failed on a couple of holes and I'm like, dude, this opium is nuts.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what happened.
[SPEAKER_00]: But no, I'm good on the herbs and stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure I've got some still.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or I can easily get some.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anybody making scary masks that are just like... Because I got to be honest, I don't know if I want to keep wearing this fake human mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to...
[SPEAKER_01]: When you say masks, are you talking about things like leathers or... Nobody is making things... You're not seeing anything that's like a disguise kit or anything like that?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not looking for a disguise, I'm looking for something that just covers my face.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, there are helmets.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, no helmets.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are light helmets that you could look at.
[SPEAKER_00]: I more so just want like a half mask that just covers the front side of my face because I'm, in general, always going to be wearing a robe over it.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's anything like that, then I would like to look.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are executioner masks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, what are we looking at?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, a normal executioner mask made out of cloth is maybe ten silver coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if you want something that is made out of leather, tough leather, and studded to protect the head, you could probably get that for a gold coin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there anything more?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, actually at that same place there is a mask made of
[SPEAKER_01]: Metal strips that forms to your face, but these things interlace tightly.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's more than chain mail because the strips are actual metal, but it's held together by these small little ringlets of chains.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there are still slits where the
[SPEAKER_01]: The pieces come together, but they are overlapping.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's kind of like a metal mask, a flexible helmet, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it just, is it like, does it wrap fully?
[SPEAKER_00]: It wraps completely around your head.
[SPEAKER_00]: With like chain mail?
[SPEAKER_00]: Around the side?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's not like chain mail.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like what it is are these strips of metal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I get that.
[SPEAKER_01]: But they're shaped.
[SPEAKER_01]: And they overlap each other in weird ways, so there's no gaps except for the eye slits in the nose.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, and then does it go all the way around, or is it...?
[SPEAKER_01]: It goes all the way up the head and around the head, and of course there's different geometries on the stuff on top.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's very lightweight, and actually what you feel is it would be more comfortable
[SPEAKER_01]: They say a solid mask or even the leather mask because air can come through it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, no, I doubt.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: That looks nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: How bright?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this like super shiny metal that like with the glare of light just bleams or is it like more darkened?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it have a dark tone to it?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, do you...
[SPEAKER_01]: This one is shiny.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can work with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, do you want to ask the guy that's selling it?
[SPEAKER_01]: A question?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, um... Can you make it less shiny?
[SPEAKER_00]: He looks at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: There he goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, you want the Killers version.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Reaches under this thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes...
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not a member of the guards, are you?
No.
[SPEAKER_01]: He takes it, he puts it down on the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: Blackened, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Still got that metal.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's still the same thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: He goes, these are used by the monks of the Scarlet Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_01]: So be careful.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those that recognize this,
[SPEAKER_01]: May mistake you for one of those kind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I'll have to do something with the... alright, cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this acceptable to you?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's metal.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like metals, but it's been etched in such a way that it's darkened.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not completely black, but like a dull gray.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which seems to be even better.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll... yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, God.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fifteen gold coins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll give him fifteen gold coins.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is a good deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is a great deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're lucky I'm desperate.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll give you five more gold pieces for your time.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a great deal.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm down.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got 62 gold pieces.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got everything I want.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's Boogie?
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk out of the marketplace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which way do I go, though?
[SPEAKER_00]: What time of night is it?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's actually very late.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's probably around midnight now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I've got to be quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I don't want to be tired in the morning.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna go back the way I came.
[SPEAKER_00]: As soon as I get out the marketplace though, I'm gonna find a corner.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where I can take this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I take it off pretty easily?
[SPEAKER_01]: The mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, the mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, yeah, then I'll just take this off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so do you want to walk into the foreign district through the archways?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that's open.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, there's no guards on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there are people that come and go from there into the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a big marketplace in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's nobody there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, there are people there, but there's no guards, as it were.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you walk through, and you want to find an alleyway?
[SPEAKER_00]: More so just a corner, not an alleyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you walk over to the side of the building.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not falling for that, bro.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not going down no alleyway to get, like, mugged.
[SPEAKER_01]: And take off your thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you want to strip your mask off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And put it...
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't care what happens to it, if I'm being honest.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to just throw it on the ground or you want to keep it?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's good for disguises because you can paint it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll keep it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you put the other mask off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You sit there and make the change.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's move.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now I definitely feel more confident.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now I can walk with confidence.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so do you put the cloak back over your head?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I put the cloak back over.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you walked out of the street.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually the battle mask is better.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's cooler.
[SPEAKER_01]: It feels nicer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does it give me any AC or no?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is somebody calling you?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it was just text messages from my family group chat.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll talk about it later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk down the street back up towards the Royal District.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll Perception.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dude, five.
[SPEAKER_00]: What in the world?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's like three fives in a row.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: You walk past a tavern.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're about halfway back up towards where you want to go.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you walk past a tavern that's kind of still loud.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're still on the main street.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something hits your head from behind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: However, luckily, the
[SPEAKER_01]: The metal mask you have, and the cushion of your cloak deflects it, and you take no damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it in there?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: It speeds past you, and you realize that it's a sling bolt.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, a sling stone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I turn around quickly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll an ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oops, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear a shout behind you, someone saying...
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you hear the sound of, the whooshing sound of another sling.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven, fifteen, another bolt knocks off your shoulder, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Luckily, your studded leather armor protects you from this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You realize that they're not using
[SPEAKER_01]: Normal sling stones are using the lead ones.
[SPEAKER_01]: These stones are used basically to kill people.
[SPEAKER_01]: A lot of times the sling stones will be like either rocks or baked clay that shatter when they hit.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's if you're trying to subdue people or knock them out.
[SPEAKER_01]: The lead ones, however, they're to kill.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many of them are there?
[SPEAKER_01]: How many people are there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, turn around, crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Delayed crossbow I got.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you turn around, right, and you see two people maybe 30 feet away in an alleyway sitting there with their slings.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um...
[SPEAKER_01]: So you basically want to cock back your light crossbow?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Low and narrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So they're sitting there physically trying to re-look through their slings.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you don't want to close on them.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're 30 feet away.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can get to them right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just go, okay, we're doing this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: And pull out your light crossbow and pull it back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: And do you want to move at all?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do you want to switch?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you just go, God damn you.
[SPEAKER_01]: To shoot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which one do you want to shoot at?
[SPEAKER_01]: Shoot at.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right or left?
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's gonna be... sweet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: You go... and let your bolt fly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you hit...
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the guys, straight on, we have to see what the damage is.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is going to be 2 die 8 plus 6, because you got a crit.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's a die 8.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, isn't it 8, and then you roll, it's an 8 automatically, and then... No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you get a critical, the amount of damage you do is what you normally do doubled.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if you do 1 die 8 plus 4, it becomes 2 die 8 plus 4.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I see what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you roll two of those.
[SPEAKER_01]: So find another die eight inside the thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And roll it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's ten plus six, sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your bolt hits the guy in the neck and he instantly drops.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, do you want to move at all?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's the other guy do?
[SPEAKER_00]: He runs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, that's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, I just gotta like holster back up and...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so the guy on the ground is sitting there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just gonna walk up to him or do you just want to walk away?
[SPEAKER_00]: Ooh, which one is way more cooler?
[SPEAKER_00]: I could walk away and that's like total... Don't give a shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or I could just walk up to him and like...
[SPEAKER_00]: To be honest, does he look like he's, this was like, at random they target people, or?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just, if I had to guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the question is this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why would you have to guess?
[SPEAKER_01]: And then nefarious wheels start turning in Paul's mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're gonna be
[SPEAKER_01]: In the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: I should be known.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or have spies.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't know if this man's dead yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wouldn't it be interesting to maybe take him as a prisoner and learn from him?
[SPEAKER_01]: He did attack a member of the royal family.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, it was unbeknownst.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whatever the case, what he did was a crime.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy's an urchin.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why did he attack you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was it for money?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why did he select you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, I'm gonna holster my crossbow, walk up to him slowly, not running.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm assuming, does he just lean himself against a wall?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, he's just sitting there like, blood coming out of his wound.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna bend down over to him, like, you know, crouch down and say... What's your name?
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously he cannot speak because of the wound.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: However... Can I save him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, if you want to, you can administer... Let's do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you...
[SPEAKER_01]: Put your hand on his forehead and pull out the crossbow bolt.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your name?
[SPEAKER_01]: And slide that back into your teeth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, this is like... You don't want to lose arrows now, do you?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Blood begins to spurt out of his neck.
[SPEAKER_01]: And, do you want to try and stop the bleeding?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you basically take your thumb and put it on his neck there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now...
[SPEAKER_01]: I am going to have to roll three saving throws.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the way you do it in Pi V. If you roll below a 10, that's one mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then if you roll above a 10, that's another mark.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need two to live.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need three to live, three to die.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you roll a one, it's two to die.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you roll a 20, it's two to live.
[SPEAKER_01]: You are gonna help this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're gonna- So he gets an advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Supply medicine.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically you go up there and begin to- I just shoved my thumb in the hole.
[SPEAKER_01]: You shoved your thumb in the hole.
[SPEAKER_01]: So here's his first roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: An advantage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Those are two 12s.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the first one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Mark for good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next one is a one, well a seven, so two for good, one for good, one for bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two for good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Last one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you managed to stabilize him.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's still unconscious.
[SPEAKER_01]: You take a little bit of the clay and put it on the wound to block it off.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's your name?
[SPEAKER_00]: He's unconscious.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, he's unconscious.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't really want to haul him out of here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_01]: You have a dungeon in the Robert Palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dude, I'm like on a roll right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know who saw me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure somebody did.
[SPEAKER_00]: But right now the word is spreading.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't mess with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if I haul them out, it's just gonna look a little weird.
[SPEAKER_00]: But can I wake them up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there anything I got to wake them up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like a... Got some smelling salts or... Well...
[SPEAKER_01]: Not necessarily to wake him up, but there's a wheelbarrow not too far away.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's stuck his head in the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I mean, it's a wheelbarrow.
[SPEAKER_01]: You could stick him in the wheelbarrow and card him like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or, if you want to, you can leave him here and get the guards to collect him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And actually maybe that's the best thing, is get the guards to get him and take him- Just take him to the dungeon and I'll deal with him later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Take him to some dungeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: It could be the palace dungeon or it could be Lord Jamis' dungeon or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you make sure the man is alive.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you walk away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Back to the gatehouse of where the-
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, guard was that you talked to.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you walk up, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the guard says, who goes there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, Rivera.
[SPEAKER_01]: The gates open up and you walk through.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I walk up and I tell him that, um...
[SPEAKER_00]: I was attacked.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you say to him?
[SPEAKER_00]: I say to him, I was attacked.
[SPEAKER_00]: I shot a man with a crossbow.
[SPEAKER_00]: He fell to the floor.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want that man in the dungeon where I can find him later.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_00]: Shall we keep him in the guardhouse here?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, in my personal castle dungeon or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: The palace?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need him for later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Will you tell the palace guards that we're bringing this man to you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Certainly.
[SPEAKER_00]: I tell him where he should be.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll send a patrol out right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you walk back up the hill.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is probably the coolest thing I've ever done on D&D.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you return, getting back to the palace at about 1 a.m. in the morning.
[SPEAKER_00]: I tell the guards about them bringing up a prisoner of mine, a personal interest to me, and that he should not be harmed, and just leave him in the dungeon and leave him to me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_01]: You return to your room.
[SPEAKER_00]: I return to my room.
[SPEAKER_00]: With your clay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Drop my clay, take it all off, I'm going to bed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, let's...